Tommy my goddamn hero a look I love you
Tommy along you but there is a man there
is a man that is even greater
the one he owned the main the men that
is Neal Greene my name is Neal free
filmmakers remember that name Neal rain
say it with me Neal me hi thanks for
checking out my crowdfunding site my
name is Neal Breen I'm a filmmaker ah
wait a minute some of you may know I've
already made aa new hi this is Neal
Briony it's June 22nd 2015 and I really
wanted to come out just update everyone
yeah shirt and so on is a symbol and it
was the best goddamn chroma key usage
I've ever seen it blends perfectly it's
goddamn beautiful it almost feels like
he's saying all right so this is a view
to neoprene I love you if you're
watching I want you to know I love you I
love you so much
I think you are an inspiration he made a
move Neal Breen made a movie called
fateful finding it got recommended to me
because I love the room so much fateful
finding is on a whole new level it might
even be too far and but I thought we you
guys loved the room video that I did I
wanted to do one on fateful findings
because I think it's one of the classics
don't get me wrong it's painful to watch
but it's also one of the funniest things
you'll ever see I'm going to try and go
through my favorite moments and by the
end of it my goal is that you go and
check out the movie yourself I'll leave
a link to where you can buy this movie
and he will autograph it and send it to
you apparently so definitely go support
the mandamus meal breehn so he can make
more beautiful timeless art pieces like
this one anyway let's watch it's a Neal
Breen film by a
neil bream it just it just through it's
a name up their unit you know what these
mountains need my name yeah the
framerate on the [ __ ] mountain make
me makes me want to throw out what genre
is this movie you might ask well I'll
let you judge for yourself
oh my god how did it do that ad it's the
scariest thing I've ever seen
look we up a mushroom look red mushroom
can't hold it whoa whoa 420 joke in the
woods smoke I don't understand sniff dog
off the shot or what's happening
the higher the [ __ ] thing alright I
don't know I don't know why I don't know
what's happening it I don't know I'm
still not at least the room it's
coherent okay I don't know what's hot
what's happening crazed Dylan no sorry
effect did you not see him right in
front of you you [ __ ] idiot Jesus
Christ
that is not how you wave that I know I
make a lot of Nazi jokes but can someone
explain why she's doing this
why she do why she doing that okay I
don't understand what is that
stop Wall Street Journal you bet I do
something about Neal breed because
fashions are getting off of his work now
if you're a younger viewer you might
want to close your eyes it gets a little
intense
[Music]
southern Nintendo switch that look real
let's go frame by frame I look [ __ ]
really [ __ ] hey still frame of it I mean
silly works right doing doing what's
going on top oh yeah I forgot about the
porn actress [ __ ] me do it what's going
on talk to me
we were supposed to use the bananas did
he dead
is he dead
it's the Rolls Royce that meeting I'm
sorry what other [ __ ] car would it be
it's right [ __ ] there like it has
blood it has blood all over it
god damn genius god damn genius
another's blood on the switch god damn
it
[Music]
is he breathing okay
you're reaching for the most prized
possession it's which it had just killed
one of the guardians in Zelda god damn
it Neil Breen I think now is the point
in movie where he goes south and it goes
south very fast I can't explain what I'm
about to show you this is like when Luke
Skywalker took off the mask of dark
Vader why did he need that anyway by the
way okay great what is that thing why is
that thing on his face why does it look
like that what purpose does it have it
looked like it took snow and try to make
himself into a snowman how do you
breathe through that you don't need
those things I told you he's not human
looks are very delicate hands I gotta
say I would love for Neal to touch me
all right of course we have the same
[ __ ] ass shot like in the room great
thanks for that
okay what you might see now it might
shock you okay I let myself song holy
holy
I can't I can't
I'm sorry I'm not gonna I'm
oh my god can you imagine filming that
without laughing
why are you still wearing the snowman
face why is he wearing it oh oh my god I
can't I can't I can't what the spa how
take it off please
take it off take it off please take it
off please got oh thank God it's over
now Neil I don't know what your deal
with computers are and I don't know why
you want to mess with them so much first
of all why do you need four laptops now
question number one why do you need four
laptops
question number two they're clearly not
working but that's okay I'll ignore that
one but why why do you have to hurt them
[Music]
don't don't touch the computers Neil now
dammit dammit wanna say what I what I
say what I say what I say god dammit
leave me alone I've got work to do
the delivery and the passion in his
crack is incredible it may just come
across a stale way of saying leave me
alone I've got work to do
but really it's things so much more Neil
Neil do not smell the coffee be careful
be careful with that coffee nail no Neil
Neil focus focus dammit focus put down
the coffee put down the goddamn coffee
Neil yes oh thank god oh don't spell it
oh thank god hittin spelling
whoa I thought another laptop that would
have been such a waste
alright well at least that's one good
thing about this theme oh god damn it
god [ __ ] damn it then it will be
ready soon
I'm hungry I can't wait for dinner
the sexual undertones of this is so
[ __ ] weird it's as weird I don't know
how old she's supposed to be but it's
weird it's weird
the real hotness of this show is Nia
look at that smile if I melt every time
it cannot be replicated I can only try
so where should you only never get done
I'm going to continue hacking into these
government systems that explains all the
laptops that explains all the laptops it
could attacking into the government
systems course of course the coffee is
it's old hacking technique now what I
remember the most from watching this
movie because there's a there's a lot of
painful bits to get through but once we
get to the end it is incredible it is
what it's one of my favorite scenes in
any movie ever
I really it'd be it's fine anything ever
and if you make it to the end
god bless you because you you get
rewarded all over the world
I have discovered more information than
any hacker ever had ever
WikiLeaks mark what I have found will
shock you okay
I'm afraid of going to prison they now
know my crimes
okay what are you gonna do ah I'm afraid
of going to prison I now know what I
must do sure surely this guy is not just
going to [ __ ] shoot him to operate in
a deceiving way and cheat the customer
goodbye now now now now ah their systems
that are there to undermine society's
best interest for the purpose of greed
and fraud
now what's out Neal there's a data
this is Napa Neal oh yeah yeah oh my god
did he die
did he done No
who did it who did it
any of the above listed companies in the
credits with an N or a B in their name
are fixed this work was actually done
personally by Nia Breen so basically
sound editing was done by Neal editing
was done by Neal casting was done by Nia
it's all done by Neal the whole movie is
Neal he's all the other people too I
love this movie I think it's amazing I
think you will enjoy it too it brings a
lot of joy this movie to me and I don't
want more people to experience that but
do please check out the link in
description and buy the movie if you
want to see it get some friends together
and watch it I think you'll really enjoy
it
let me like you enjoyed watching let me
know if you want me to do more of these
type of movies I find them a very it's
always fun to share stuff that I'm
passionate about and really enjoy so
thank you for watching dancing